قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن انه يشعر
بحزن عميق بسبب الخسائر في الارواح
والدمار نتيجه الزلزال في تركيا وسوريا
وذكر البيت الابيض انه يعتزم ارسال مزيد
من الفرق تتضمن 200 وتسعه وسبعين فردا
لمساعده تركيا في اعمال البحث والانقاذ
اما مسؤول العلاقات الخارجيه بالاتحاد
الاوروبي فاعلنا ان عشرا من دول الاتحاد
تقدم مساعدات
للمشاركه في عمليات الانقاذ منها بلغاريا
ورومانيا وهولندا وفرنسا وعربت روسيا عن
استعدادها لتقديم مساعدات واتصل الرئيس
بوتين بالرئيس السوري بشار الاسد وبعث
رساله تعزيه للرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان واعلنت الخارجيه القطريه انطلاقه
اولى رحلات الجسر الجوي الذي خصصته قطر
الى تركيا لدعمها في مواجهتك كارثه
الزلزال كما اعلنت وزاره الاعلام الكويتيه
عن تسيير جسر جوي الى تركيا لتقديم
مساعدات واتقوا من طبيه لا وعربه تيران
على استعدادها لمساعده الضحايا في كل من
تركيا وسوريا واعلنت عزمها ارسال ست فرق
انقاذ الى تركيا لتقديم لمساعده في عمليات
الامداد وتنسيقها كما اعلنت بريطانيا
استعدادها لتقديم مساعدات فوريه لتركيا
ومزيد من الدعم للخوزات البيضاء
في سوريا واقلت اليابان انها سترسل فريقا
مكونا من خمسه وسبعين فردا للمساهمه في
عمليات الانقاذ